three years ago Amazon accused my
husband of a federal crime they had the
federal government seize our bank
accounts via civil forfeiture they
raided our home with guns and so much
more that's Amy Turner Nelson the FED
seized almost 1 million dollars from her
and her husband Carl after they allege
he had participated in an illegal real
estate scheme the Nelsons lost hundreds
of thousands of dollars even though he
has yet to be charged with a crime he's
called civil forfeiture cops can take
your assets without the government
having to convict you of anything law
enforcement agencies take billions of
dollars a year in civil forfeiture
Detroit cops seized two of Stephanie
Wilson's cars after they alleged her
boyfriend was a petty drug offender she
was never even suspected of a crime
Michigan law enforcement Pockets 95 to
100 percent of the proceeds from civil
forfeiture which is the case in many
states across this country so you can
understand why they like the status quo
innocent people often have to wait years
to get their stuff back some never get
it back at all we should all agree that
the government should not be able to
steal from its own citizens